[Música]
escala en París Aída Palau
Bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio Francia internacional y de Franz
24 la bacteria que originó la peste
negra y que mató a millones de personas
en Europa durante la Edad Media Todavía
vive se trata de la yersinia pestis y en
la actualidad sigue activa en algunas
zonas del mundo vamos a hablar de la
peste y de su evolución y lo hacemos con
el científico costarricense Javier
Pizarro Cerda del instituto pasto de
París Javier muchas gracias y bienvenido
Buenos días ayuda Gracias bueno Javier
recientemente junto a su equipo han
hecho un montón de descubrimientos no
sobre la peste y sobre cómo algunos
humanos consiguieron sobrevivir a ella
gracias a sus genes Pero antes de todo
vamos a explicar un poco Qué es la peste
negra que ha sido una de las peores
pandemias de la historia de la humanidad
junto con por ejemplo la viruela la
gripe o la actual de Kobe 19 la peste
mató entre 1347 y 1352 a una gran
proporción la población europea hablamos
de millones y millones de personas
explíquenos que es la peste y cómo se
origina pues la peste es una enfermedad
causada por una bacteria que como dijo
se llama yersinia pestis una bacteria
que se encuentra sobre todo presente en
poblaciones de roedores en diferentes
lugares del mundo y es transmitida por
las pulgas de estos roedores y la pesa
es una una bacteria muy muy patógena la
enfermedad es fulminante una persona
puede morir en 24 horas después de haber
sido infectado con esta bacteria y
precisamente como mencionaba en el
medioevo una gran pandemia de peso hubo
una antes en el Imperio Romano que
también fue muy terrible pero el
medioevo murieron se calcula que en
Europa entre 30 y 50 millones de
personas debido a esta a esta enfermedad
terrible la peste originalmente no era
tan patógena No justamente en el
instituto pasto tiene una colección muy
importante
de bacterias recogidas en todas las
partes geográficas del planeta las están
analizando para entender cómo se
convirtió este patógeno en este monstruo
que mató a tanta gente Cuántas hay
Cuántas están manejando para hacer estos
descubrimientos estamos manejando miles
de bacterias hoy en día gracias a las
técnicas de secuenciación de ADN tenemos
acceso no sólo a bacterias actuales
tenemos muchísimas bacterias que vienen
de Asia África América gracias a las
diferentes interacciones del instituto
pasteur con otros institutos en el mundo
Entonces en el pastel tenemos más de
2.000 sepas que estamos secuenciando y
analizando su ADN y Tenemos
colaboraciones también con arqueólogos
que trabajan con bacterias antiguas que
han rescatado de cementerios de hace
1.000 2.000 incluso 5000 años entonces
estamos retrasando toda la historia de
esta bacteria para entender precisamente
Cómo se transformó originalmente viene
de un bacilo que causa una enfermedad
intestinal y poco a poco fue cambiando y
fue evolucionando a este patógeno que
conocemos hoy en día y han conseguido
encontrar ese vacilo tan o sea
identificarlo el que fue tan tan tan
mortal pues tenemos pistas sobre este
vacilo mortal Es realmente como un
rompecabezas tenemos diferentes hemos
visto diferentes moléculas que ayudan a
causar esta enfermedad tan tan grave y
eso en este momento estamos poniendo
juntas precisamente las piezas de este
rompecabezas para tener la imagen global
de este vacilo y entender Por qué está
mortal
eso explicaría no que se convirtieran se
transformaran mucho más agresivos os
explicaría Por qué mató a tanta gente en
la Edad Media no hablamos de no sé 30
millones 40 millones de personas 50
millones no saben muy bien
definitivamente Y eso nos está dando
pista de Por qué es tan patógeno de
hecho es una bacteria que se transmite
inicialmente por las pulgas
infecta los gangliones y luego de ahí
pasa todo el cuerpo y hay una variante
de esta peste que puede llegar a los
pulmones y que se puede transmitir
exactamente como el covid y pensamos que
tal vez en algunas de estas pandemias
del medioevo la gente transmitía a la
vía la tos esta bacteria y en ese en ese
caso se vuelve una enfermedad muy muy
peligrosa porque entonces hay contacto
la transmisión de mano a mano de hecho
ahora durante la pandemia de coronavirus
se han recuperado un poco gestos que ya
se aplicaron durante
esas pandemias de hace siglos no
definitivamente por ejemplo el pase
sanitario es algo que se había
establecido ya en Italia en el siglo 18
ahí tenemos hoy hoy día ejemplos de
pases sanitarios que se que se dieron en
ese momento para viajar del Norte al sur
de Italia el gel que nos ponemos hoy en
día cuando entramos al supermercado
Cuando vamos a algún restaurante resulta
que en Inglaterra todavía en algunas
ciudades existen piedras en por medio de
la ciudad Piedras que son como un tubo
donde tenemos un un espacio donde se
ponía vinagre entonces la gente los
peatones cuando transitaban se lavaban
las manos con vinagre igual como hacemos
hoy con el gel o el mismo término
cuarentena se inventó en dubrovnik En
Croacia en 1377 para identificar el
período que los barcos tenían que
esperar antes de llegar al puerto y 700
años después hemos aplicado este tipo de
de gestos otra de las investigaciones en
las que ha participado y que está
actualmente en revisión en la revista
nature es la siguiente si las personas
que sobrevivieron a la peste en la Edad
Media tenía genes de resistencia a la
bacteria en su sistema inmunitario y si
esos genes han sido transmitidos hasta
hasta hoy A qué conclusión han llegado
pues como la peste mató a tantas
personas en el medio Evo una presión muy
fuerte sobre las poblaciones humanas y
teníamos la hipótesis de tal vez algunas
personas tenían mutaciones que les
permitían
resistir a la peste entonces con colegas
en Chicago en Montreal hemos estado
investigando esqueletos de gente que
murió de peste en el medioevo en Londres
en Inglaterra en 1347 1350 y después y
hemos identificado precisamente un gen
que permite desarrollar una respuesta
inmune mucho más fuerte Entonces tenemos
tenemos que esta investigación es
estamos al inicio únicamente Pero
tenemos una pista muy fuerte que este
Gen probablemente protegió a una gran
parte de la población humana de la peste
Pero eso no es beneficioso del todo no
para según que personas explíquenos
esas mutaciones pueden ser también ser
negativas esas mutaciones tienen un lado
oscuro se podríamos decirle y
precisamente se ha visto que hoy en día
algunas personas por ejemplo que
desarrollan lo que es la enfermedad de
crohn que es una enfermedad del
intestino es una inflamación un poco
agresiva el intestino y nos damos cuenta
que este Gen está presente Precisamente
en estas personas que tienen la
enfermedad de crohn entonces nuestra
hipótesis hoy en día es que una
enfermedad Como la hicrón es el precio
que estamos pagando por haber
sobrevivido de la peste en el pasado
Porque hay lugares en el mundo donde aún
hay peste porque pensamos que es una
enfermedad Ya del pasado Pero hay
lugares hay países donde regularmente
hay casos de peste sí la bueno la peste
desapareció en Europa desde mitad del
siglo 19 el último caso en Francia fue
en córcega en 1945 sin embargo la
desaparición de la peste está muy ligado
a la al incremento de las medidas de
higiene y los lugares nos da y peste hoy
en día son lugares donde Hay muy poca
higiene Madagascar por ejemplo zona de
guerra República democrática del Congo
Entonces cuando tenemos la conjunción de
Estos factores tenemos mucho
acercamiento entre relaciones humanas y
ratas por ejemplo que son los
reservorios y podemos decir de esta
enfermedad Cuando surgen estos brotes
hay que estar muy alerta No porque si es
una peste digamos pulmonar podría
extenderse a nivel mundial no como ha
pasado con el covid definitivamente y de
hecho en el 2017 Madagascar hubo un
brote de peste pulmonar y y aquí en
París estuvimos incluso muy alertas los
aeropuertos de París los hospitales de
París estuvieron estuvieron alerta en el
caso de que hubiera caso de peste que
vinieran de Madagascar hay antibióticos
pero no todo el mundo tiene acceso las
zonas por ejemplo Rurales y como ustedes
ya puede matar en 24-48 horas la peste
si no tiene acceso a sus antibióticos
pues se puede resultar con una
mortalidad alta no un brote en las
vacunas que se desarrollaron no eran muy
eficaces pero ustedes ya están
trabajando en otra vacuna contra la
peste explíquenos en efecto los
antibióticos pueden funcionar pero
precisamente de Madagascar en la zona
Rurales a veces no existen esos
antibióticos y las vacunas que se han
desarrollado hoy en día son vacunas
antiguas que tienen una protección
temporal muy corta Entonces nosotros
estamos trabajando una nueva vacuna de
Nueva Generación y de momento los
experimentos que hemos realizado en
roedores muestran una protección
realmente muy efectiva contra peste
bubónica contra peste pulmonar nuestro
próximo paso es pasar a experimentación
en primates antes de pasar a tratar a
humanos
no sé si se pueden comparar las
bacterias y los virus Pero bueno vamos a
intentar hacerlo me comentaba que las
bacterias también mutan no al igual que
que los virus que tal enlacen de forma
más lenta pero también mutan la peste
sigue siendo tan agresiva como hace
cientos de años sin embargo con el
covito hemos visto que con la variante
omicron
las consecuencias y las personas son
mucho menos graves por lo que estamos
viendo no vamos a generalizar porque
sigue habiendo casos graves pero podría
ser que la peste también o porque la
peste no no no ha mutado hacia algo
menos grave es un excelente pregunta y
la peste en realidad es uno de los
patógenos bacterianos más recientes
probablemente la patógeno más reciente
que ha surgido estamos hablando de un
periodo de mil dos mil años pero en
términos evolutivos es muy poco tiempo
Entonces como usted mencionaba las
bacterias mutan menos si damos un tiempo
de unos miles de años podría ser que en
el futuro la peste pierda un poco de su
patogenicidad pero hoy en día sigue
siendo un patógeno tan tan agresivo como
lo fue en el medioevo querría tener su
opinión sobre sobre el coronavirus como
científico
puede ser que al igual que con la
yersinia pestis que es este bacilo de la
peste
haya gente que sea genéticamente
resistente al covid 19 es posible
definitivamente tenemos un repertorio
muy amplio de genes de sistema inmune
que podría haber algunas personas
probablemente permitirles ser más
fuertes y más resistentes al coronavirus
sin embargo la presión la agresividad
del coronavirus es mucho menos que la
del bacilo de la peste entonces
probablemente va a ser un poco más
difícil que esas mutaciones queden en la
población Además de que hoy en día
tenemos muchas medidas de tratamientos
que nos permiten precisamente
utilizar otras herramientas que no
existían en el pasado la peste afecta
por igual a personas sanas jóvenes
mayores pero con el coronavirus vemos
Que bueno las personas más frágiles son
las personas mayores
las personas enfermas
la bacteria Perdón la bacteria de la
peste afecta por igual a todo el mundo
por igual realmente
hoy en día no se han detectado
diferencias ni de sexo ni de edad es una
bacteria sumamente agresiva y tiene la
capacidad de causar una enfermedad muy
grave En cualquier persona Bueno pues
muchísimas gracias Javier Pizarro Cerda
por haber venido hasta nuestros estudios
y por aclararnos
todo tipo de dudas que teníamos sobre la
peste y le deseamos muchísima suerte con
sus investigaciones Muchísimas gracias a
ella y muchas gracias a todos ustedes
por habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir también por internet en rf
y mundo.com
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]